Case Keenum the Vikings quarterback and
one of McLovin boyfriends as he has a
new man crush it feels like every year
on a quarterback and this year it is
Case Keenum next year when case is
playing for the Cleveland Browns McLovin
probably won't care about him oh come on
yes Paulie we do have a major breaking
story though McLovin often dresses like
the people he admires and his friends
with fritzy going boot Bros with Case
Keenum this morning take a look how
about that I took a chance and there we
are
hijacking the friendship case do you
have a large pimple on the side of your
face like poke seaton in the eye it's
the dry the dry weather I would say
maybe it was that plunge II took but I
don't think he got when you slip into a
bathtub you know that's what fritzy did
in the Polar Plunge he tried to slip in
raised all this money for charity who
gets booed at raising $10,000 for
charity yes as do you we had Stefon
Diggs in a couple of days ago and what a
good kid man I mean he's got a lot of
personality oh yeah that young and I
said how do people react to you here in
Minneapolis he said men and women come
up and kiss me
he said hug me I said men do you yeah I
mean there and it feels like maybe you
guys never moved on from the Mack you
know the magic of all of that I know
like subconsciously maybe you didn't
consciously you did but the energy the
you guys think spent talking about it
reflecting on it celebrating it did it
affect you at all in Philadelphia you
know it could have you know it's it's
one that it's still sinking in like you
know I think the fact just I've been
watching you know digs through
interviews saw him on here and like he's
he's you know he's gonna answer that
question for the rest of his life and
I'm sure
I'm gonna be asking a lot of those same
questions and you know I don't know if
we know the magnitude of what it was but
we tried as best we could to move past
it but I mean we were getting asked
about it even on Saturday you know from
you know production meetings and stuff
so it's have you watched the film of
Minnesota against the Eagles yeah yeah
how tough it was it was tough man it
stings man
you know I know Michael Evans here is is
grinning behind me did you did you know
that he's an Eagles fan you know I had I
think I may have known it before a
little bit but like I don't know it
seems to be coming coming out even if
you'd won I'd have my face painted
purple right now I'm but you know I'll
go with the winner kid are you gonna go
to the game oh no can't do it no I'm I
don't think I'm gonna watch it this year
really do you normally not watch it I
don't I don't make a point to or to not
but I think we have a flight scheduled
at that time so you're flying out on
Super Bowl Sunday yeah on purpose
accident I'm assuming you're going to
someplace warmer yes yes we're gonna
migrate south how would you feel if this
was an outdoor stadium well I mean they
did it for a few years and there's
stories I mean those guys you know a lot
of guys on the team that were playing in
those years you know talked about the
Seattle playoff game and then there's
two or three other games that people
were I mean it was it was miserable
would you embrace a home-field advantage
you know like Green Bay has it gets a
little colder here I think that angry
Green Bay I definitely think we would we
were you know in at the game in Philly I
think it was around 40 degrees that game
enough you know we're coming out to 1ups
like this is incredible
like I know you just you live here and
you you're outdoors enough to where you
get used to let me know if you get used
to negative five like now this is a real
cold even for somebody who lives here
isn't it
yeah I mean you walk outside that first
breath you take you're like oh boy yeah
it hurts yeah it's painful you know and
you try to cover up as much you can but
yeah dealing with this makes 30 or 40
you know feel like a nice spring day
talking to Case Keenum of the Vikings
joining us Dan Patrick show if Tom Brady
were to ask you
like would you see in the Philadelphia
go what would you tell him um what can I
take advantage of Tom ask me yes you
know would that be though Brady says hey
case tom hollie I think tried to give it
to Brady will do it yeah what would you
say yeah I mean they're they're a great
defense obviously you got to take care
of the football
but what am i take what where's where's
this soft spot you know I think it's I
think they're a different team you know
playing at home I think the rush is is
really tough so it'll be up soon to see
you know how the crowd noise affects it
in here and what what that'll be like
you know up front they're really good
they really are you know in the back end
I think I think they're solid I think
those guys are all in the right place at
the right time you know but I think I
think it's a kind of a you know take
what they give you type of defense you
know if you're if you're smart with the
ball and don't you know take too big a
risk
wait but this is Brady who's asking you
yeah and you're not telling them
anything well it's really you asking me
I'm basically Brady you're basically I'm
playing the role of great like you know
Darby maybe I pick on Darby a little bit
you think so yep you know the corners to
me I thought I thought they're real
similar in my study do you guys ever
share information quarterbacks sometimes
yeah I mean there's certain guys certain
guys that you know I've never I've never
talked to Brady about anything I'll be
honest I never really asked like you're
refusing his phone calls
yeah no I'm clicking on there what
quarterback are you great friends with
ah there's a lot I mean Nick is one
fools now what if Foles asked you for
any advice well we didn't play wouldn't
play the patriots and patriots are so
gameplan I mean they change up you know
week to week you know but yeah I mean I
would I would help foals out it's kind
of one of those like is it does it does
it help you as much as it helps them
sometimes and so it's you know it's you
know it's one of those you know what do
you get in a trade bill do you know
where you're gonna be next year I have
no idea man
I don't I don't know where I'm gonna be
you know in two weeks because Alex Smith
comes on and
gets traded four hours later would you
be okay with being traded four hours
from now
you know I'd be up for anything I mean I
bet if somebody wanted you to see my my
whole problem with what happened this
year is you it felt like you had to
prove yourself each week and then coach
Zimmer to go to the press conference and
then it didn't feel like he was going
yet case is my guy it was like I he is
next week but that's how it felt to us
how did it feel to you you know I tried
to block a lot of that out you know and
I think I even made a joke to somebody
NFC weak like that I still hadn't been
named the starter you know just stopped
asking the question because coach Zimmer
answered it the same way and you know
that's great I mean that's that's how
coaches ever wanted to handle it you
know and I love play for the guy I think
you know I think he's a great coach and
but if it feels like he wants Teddy
Bridgewater back in there you know you
know it's hard for me to read you know
too far into those things I know that's
what you guys do and it's what you got
all these yes that's why every Dennis
you had to read into it yeah but but it
you know it's one of those where you're
gonna find out relatively soon I'm
guessing but what your future yeah and
and I'm I'm like I said my family were
uh you know we're excited for the future
obviously you know this year I think it
was a great chance for for us as a team
to prove what we can do for me as a as
an individual to prove you know myself
you know even on a bigger stage and what
you know what I've done before so we're
excited for what the future holds we
know we know we love it here in
Minnesota but there's a lot of golf
courses in Scottsdale case I think that
that might be like I could see that
winter clothes we're going to Scottsdale
yeah I'm sure I'm sure she would say all
right give me the credit card let's go
shopping
Larry Larry Fitzgerald picks you up at
the airport how's that so I mean I
wouldn't be mad okay all right I I feel
like we have to get you a job I mean
whatever it takes man all right I'm good
yeah any other rumors that I don't want
to send you to Buffalo I can't do that
to your wife
well it was very experienced negative
five I mean
yeah we're up for whatever we really are
I mean we've been we've been in LA you
know we've been in Minnesota now so I
think we've got the two extremes so well
we have a special presentation polling
right yeah this is really exciting case
on your behalf
case came in with a gift there's a young
fan of Case Keenum was here today he was
really excited young guy and he if he
could bring him up he's Andrew mclubbe
and Perloff you don't mind standing up
oh wow we need some help here okay wow
you spared no expense wrapping it Levin
Wow so McLovin got his Viking Jersey
says Perloff on the back
what's an Eagles fan gonna do with that
old case I'm like listen Adam feelings
white but he's really good so he gives
me a lot of credit for this season I
think I think you should put it on right
now
North lemon I think that would be nice
nice I would go a long way nice little
gesture on encases part yeah well during
the commercial break yeah would you like
to throw a couple passes to McLovin Alex
Smith once they saw the arm strength
that he immediately got traded to
Washington by the way is it era Rogers
coming by later today yeah how's he
gonna feel about that that'll be great
it's great to see a case and and once
again yeah Congrats on a great year and
hopefully get an opportunity at some
place this next season that balls been
used by now Dan Marino Alex Smith it's
got Dan Marino lik moisture on it yeah
what is it with you guys licking your
fingers I don't know it's you do out
here yeah I do I've gotten I've gotten
in a in a habit of doing it it's you get
out of the right it's weird cuz you lick
and then I then I wipe it off so it's
like the combination of those two you
look it then wipe it off yeah so it's
like I don't know why even all right so
we've had Dan Marino throw some passes
to McLovin and we've had Alex Smith who
got traded after throwing passes to
McLovin
so yes yes hey you haven't made fun of
it case Kingdom's arm strength right no
okay it's got a great arm you just see
that past except in digs and Stefon
Diggs - yeah all right let's go dig
z-man feeling like a poor man just
putting all the white guys probably you
know coaches son good hand or hard
worker okay here we go
so two throws of Case Keenum his final
throws as a Minnesota Vikings are right
here
this is what happened with Alec Smith
here we go McLovin all right let's see
here we go window who Kuechly draped all
over McLovin yeah well it's nice I got a
bull's-eye you know case doesn't throw a
catchable ball I heard one more all
right yeah case all right case right
here oh hey you may put them in the
protocol real quick thanks man I
appreciate you guys four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]